netflix's things heard and seen starring
amanda seyfried and alpacas is the
distributor's latest thriller which may
have you scratching your head and asking
what the hell was that from its cryptic
ending with a ship on fire to the
real-life teachings of emmanuel
swedenborg
this video will be taking a deep dive
and explaining some of the film's most
mysterious unanswered questions
so put on your life jackets and make
sure to like and subscribe because
we're about to go sailing to understand
the ending we must start with the very
first
image of the film a quote from swedish
scientist and theologian emmanuel
swedenborg
look it sounds swedish things that are
in heaven
are more real than things that are in
the world at the age of 53 swedenborg is
said to have been visited by
christ himself who told him to reform
christianity by writing a new heavenly
doctrine in fact his work was so well
received that a movement called the new
church sprung from his revelations
believing it to be the true word of god
and this movement gained popularity
right around the time of jacob smith and
his wife throughout the movie we get
little clues as to the house's
mysterious origins the home's first
inhabitants around the early 1800s were
jacob smith and his wife she's never
given a name in the story in fact her
name is literally written out of the
family tree replaced with
damned as floyd later finds out smith
was a strict calvinist who strongly
disapproved of his wife's philosophic
exploration
damned it's heavily implied after the
mysterious death of smith's wife at the
age of 26 that he was the one who killed
her
likely because of this difference in
religious beliefs
the house then took on each of their
spirits one good
and one evil who would later haunt
future owners
with jacob smith being a murderous
calvinist it's ironic then that the
home's next murderer is literally named
calvin
although we never see him in the movie
we do see the ghost of his wife
ella he gave his children eddie and cole
who we see throughout the film
sedatives while he let the fumes from
the car located in the garage beneath
the bedroom exfixiate him and his wife
just like calvin
george ends up giving sedatives to his
wife and child but there's a physical
object which links mrs smith ella and
catherine are story's protagonists it's
this ring originally worn by mrs smith
it's of two women comforting one another
like we see catherine and ella doing
near the end of the film
as catherine earlier says of ella's
ghostly presence
every time i sense her i i
feel comfort
ella is an angel guiding catherine to
heaven some religions call them guardian
angels
catherine's full name catherine claire
literally means pure and clear from
greek and french respectively
catherine will become such an angel too
to help guide the next poor woman to
take up residence in this damned home
it's ironic then that the art piece we
first see her restoring is that of an
angel she also drops the ring as she
dies
ready for it to be passed on to someone
new these angels do not live
in heaven or hell but in between to help
guide
but just as there are angels there are
demons the spirit of calvin is able to
easily manipulate george because
an evil spirit will only commune with an
evil tour
george is evil he forged a
recommendation to get a job teaching
college he cheats on his wife and will
even go on to commit murder
twice he also claimed the paintings of
his dead cousins as his own which will
later see him hang in floyd's office
which he
also took over this is a guy who read
his dead cousin's diary over and over
again
kinda creepy notice here how he's
already gotten rid of floyd's model
sailing boats speaking of which the
lost horizon is the boat george
inherited from this cousin which he
ironically sails in at the end of the
film
a boat which will spontaneously combust
in flames as george makes his descent
into hell as the camera pans out it's
revealed to be a painting one eerily
similar to george innis's the valley of
the shadow of death which we see on the
cover of swedenborg's book
heaven in the world of spirits and hell
george innis was inspired by swedenborg
as floyd says
he keenly understood that everything in
the natural world
has a counterpart in the spiritual realm
and in this painted landscape with us in
mind unlike innis painting though one we
see at the end has its cross
upside down which traditionally
symbolizes hell
evil or satanism it's innis's
counterpart in the beginning of the film
a projector plays a series of landscapes
like thomas cole's caterskill falls
which we actually see in the film this
is the same classroom where we later see
george teaching
this relationship between reality and
painting is expressed as the film
literally transitions from painting to
reality in the beginning
and from reality to painting at the end
these parallel worlds are also expressed
through mirrors which
several shots often show a character as
a reflection
thomas cole was a founder of the hudson
river school hudson river is where floyd
and george will later drown
although not seen cole is the painter
one of george's students brings up at
the museum
specifically his work manhood which is
one of four paintings in a collection
called the voyage of life
in it we see a sailor who has let go of
the tiller as george says
uh it's when cole believes we uh we lose
the confidence of youth
uh go go check out the sailors hands
they're no longer on the tiller
this is exactly what happens to george
at the end he lets go of the tiller
unlike cole's painting however he does
not put his hands together to pray and
the guardian angel watching over him
well
isn't an angel i wouldn't be surprised
if cole the kid in the movie is named
after this painter
especially considering he ventures into
manhood staring at catherine's breasts
and later having to deal with the
reality he unknowingly drugged franny
and looked after her while catherine was
already dead
upstairs you may also be curious to find
out that the painting behind george when
he visits the museum is also a thomas
cole painting called the vale
and the temple of suggesta vale is eddie
and cole's last name before they changed
it it's also a play on words meaning
three different things a
valley the earthly world and if spelled
v-e-i-l-a cover
ghosts are sometimes said to be hidden
by veils not the physical kind but a
veil or cover between worlds
the beginning of the film starts with a
scene that occurs near the end where
george has framed eddie for the murder
of his wife
it seems this guy doesn't have much luck
especially considering that's his last
name
notice how frannie the daughter here
wears blue in fact the story
incorporates blue in the costumes for
much of the characters especially
catherine like at her daughter's
birthday when she visits the historical
society
chats with eddie or her blue jeans the
night she's axed
in the catholic church the virgin mary
is often depicted as wearing blue to
symbolize grace and divine favor and in
most cultures the color is commonly
associated with sadness so you can see
why the filmmakers decided to
incorporate a lot of it throughout the
film
there is great importance stressed on
the dynamic between catherine and george
it's hinted that catherine's purging may
be a result of george's views on women
and their bodies
after coming home from dinner at
justine's he says of her she can
certainly put away some lasagna
ultimately catherine wants to be a good
wife and please her husband and staying
thin
is a part of that as she tells justine i
guess you could say i'm a conflicted
catholic girl at heart
dutifully going through the motions
george is a man who always gets what he
wants and catherine has put
everything aside for him even moving
from the big city to be with him
george clare always gets exactly what he
wants there's even a subtle hint that
catherine
may have had an abortion which she was
pressured into by
george she pulls out a weird fetus-like
thing from the drain in one of her
nightmares as george watches behind her
she's more spiritual and religious so it
might not be as big of a deal for
george than her her mother says on the
phone try to remember how he did right
before she is cut off this suggests he
may have had franny out of wedlock and
he married her because it was the right
thing to do
after all we learn they met as
undergrads in college before they had
built their careers the song eddie plays
on the piano is
someday you'll be sorry by louis
armstrong which she says is quote the
story of her life catherine has created
her
own prison yeah we all choose our own
prison
willis also has a difficult history with
men after having sex with george she
asks herself why she keeps doing this
she believes all men are like her father
manipulative with ill intentions
dad made a fortune defending all of them
thieves
con men psychopaths and they all got up
because that's the way the world works
for men there seems to be no justice for
the women in this film their histories
literally erased by powerful
manipulative men
it's ironic then that a woman named
justine is the one to deliver justice to
george you may have also heard mozart's
lacrimosa play shortly before
catherine's death
this is the piece of music she finds
under the piano when she first
arrives at the home mozart died while
composing this piece which was
originally commissioned to commemorate
count von valssag's dead wife on the
anniversary of her death this
foreshadowing is also echoed through the
use of
animals a vulture-like bird is seen on
the top of her chimney and the night
before her murder a raven smashes
through her window
both creatures synonymous with death
although the film does end quite
tragically there is a glimmer of hope as
the voice over exclaims evil like george
never wins
and that catherine's death does not mean
she's gone her spirit
still lives on he'd say death is only
the beginning
have you read the book yet but what did
you think of things seen and heard
leave me a comment below and make sure
to hit that like and subscribe button
for more bad takes you can also follow
me on twitter and instagram at think
story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much